sie alle waren auf und davon
familie dobler aus dem thurgau sucht das
große abenteuer in australien lange und
hans jörg jäger aus dem aargau bauern in
thailand eine seniorenresidenz familie
tänzer aus dem kanton bern träumt von
einem besseren leben und wagt den
neuanfang in florida wiedersehen mit
hermann schönbächler
der bieler förster und seine familie
haben das glück tief im kanadischen wald
gefunden
[Musik]
seit zwei jahren lebt hermann
schönbächler mit seiner familie in
kanada baby alexandra kam hier auf die
welt ich habe ganz große stärke der
bruchstelle energie mit oma zattler
behandlung bevor er mit einem lachen
lachen um es mal seit einem schweren
sturm konnte der förster kaum mehr im
wald arbeiten doch das kam ihm gerade
recht
er nutzte die zeit und plante mit seiner
frau christina einen auto unterstand
plane und ranziger packten ihr leben in
einem container der abschied von ihren
liebsten viel in thailand auswanderern
schwer
[Musik]
rolf dobler und sein sohn kevin waren
vorausgereist um in australien an haus
zu finden bevor der rest der familie
eintrifft
doch sie wohnen noch immer auf den
campingplatz
dennis und gleich denzer reisten kreuz
und quer durch florida sie suchten ein
heimeliges nest für ihre familie und
fanden nur enttäuschungen
[Musik]
aromat gehört für christine schönbächler
noch immer zu einem guten essen
sie führt in kanada ganz bewusst einen
schweizer haushalt natascha und ricky
sprechen aber bereits englisch
miteinander das studieren oder die
schweiz
dass die heime schweizer deutschland
braucht blieb in ihr relativ strikt das
waren sie mit blockieren auf englisch
sagen das ist nicht erstaunt und nach
deutschland im kindergarten jetzt schon
buchstabieren und probiere das alles
vielleicht noch
[Musik]
welche netz von o2
wenn ich sage das erste hd musste
blieben danach zu suchen
hermann schönbächler schafft platz für
den geplanten auto unterstand
oder schaut nicht wenn man sich auf
aufholjagd wird das jahr verteilt wird
es mit das muss aber die großen zittern
[Musik]
zu einer tasche schule ist es ein weiter
weg und nicht immer fährt der schulbus
[Musik]
das habe so wie dieser einer deiner
größe vorhanden
[Musik]
natascha besucht seit zwei wochen die
erste klasse in der schule von horst
noch braucht die sechsjährige natascha
nachhilfestunden in englisch sie hat in
englisch große fortschritte gemacht und
sich natascha kennenlernte konnte sie
zwar viele worte sie konnte aber keine
sätze bilden
das ist schwierig
[Musik]
die hatten und sie werden gegen viren
rolf dobler und sein sohn kevins in zwei
wochen früher als der rest der familie
nach australien gereist
in der kleinstadt sheriff müssen sie ein
haus finden bevor mutter emma und kevins
zwei kleine geschwister hier ankommt sie
sind noch in der schweiz bodenleger
sollte man sein
rolf dobler beruf ist in australien sehr
gefragt darum hat die familie eine der
begehrten aufenthaltsbewilligungen
bekommen welche maschine beim gomez das
alles nicht
[Musik]
noch wohnen die beiden auf dem
campingplatz
rollvi seine frau immer unbedingt ein
haus präsentieren können wenn sie nach
sheraton kommt wolf die
immobilienmaklerin
er will eines der häuser von innen
besichtigen deutsche engagement
wir sind wieder wer das on the beach das
eigentlich da wo die unbedingt aber
richtig aber einfach nicht okay wenn man
noch einen kranwagen
[Musik]
nicht
beginnen wir wollen zu hause der
auswanderer erklärte maklerin er wolle
ihm erst ihr nur zur miete wohnen ein
hauskauf gummi erst in frage wenn die
familie sicher sei in jared l am
richtigen ort angekommen zu sein
es lebt sich gleich noch immer
irgendwann einmal groß vom ganze ding
oder wer kennt diesen aber noch okay vom
platz
tierisch gut täte ich jetzt sogar mein
ruf als geister
es ist das erste haus das die
auswanderer von innen besichtigen und es
ist gleich ein volltreffer
e mail oder andere freie situation zu
wenig platz
du wirst mich lieben es egal dass strand
herrscht beim 28 minuten ist minimum und
maximum 20 minuten im standard man darf
ich mit dem velo drei minuten
[Musik]
lange und hans jörg jäger haben acht
stunden fahrt hinter sich als sie in
japan eintreffen
das paar will in annies heimatdorf eine
seniorenresidenz für rentner aus der
schweiz und aus deutschland bauen
ranis eltern freuen sich dass ihre
tochter mit ihrem mann in den schoß der
familie zurück kehrt
nani hatte hansjörg vor 20 jahren
kennengelernt als dieser beruflich in
thailand war seither lebten sie
gemeinsam in der schweiz
[Musik]
[Applaus]
am ersten morgen in ihrer neuen heimat
besuchen die auswanderer das geisterhaus
es ist so etwas wie das
einwohnermeldeamt von anis heimatdorf
[Musik]
es muss dann wir auf sondern nur so vor
der großen und muss ich anmeldung ich
bin zurückgekommen planegger und
hansjörg eger
wir sind zurück vom ist reißt du hier in
der planie ecke panzerfaust wartburg
pistorius angemeldet
[Musik]
sowohl an jäger hat ein großes stück
land geerbt hier entsteht ihre residenz
rund um einen künstlichen see baut das
paar 13 balus rentner aus der schweiz
und aus deutschland sollen hierfür 1000
franken im monat ein komfortables leben
genießen
im restaurant werden dereinst nicht nur
die rentner bekocht es soll auch für
touristen und andere gäste offen stehen
die im hotel gleich nebenan übernachten
[Applaus]
[Musik]
das mini doch und willig oder mel b die
notiz sprechen
ich glaube und das verteidigen einfach
im hintergrund selbst funktioniert das
schon schwer die klinik auffenbauer sie
mir langsam ab
[Musik]
warum david esszimmer oder foto her da
geht das zimmer da nur relativ groß und
dann ist nächste und das wc und target
price und damit zurück ins freie oder
den user kommt dem einer muse das ganze
land ist anni ich eigentlich gar nicht
aber ich bin mit allen chören und von
dtcc über 20 jahre zusammen und das
enteignet in den fällen passieren
naja
[Musik]
dennis tänzer war völlig überrumpelt als
ihr mann kleider sagte er wolle nach
florida auswandern weil sie spürte wie
sehr er unter dem alltagstrott in der
schweiz litt unterstützte sie seinen
radikalen neuanfang
gegen 10 gehören aber das hus ist eine
pasta
das war jetzt werdet
sie verkauften kurzerhand ihr haus am
thunersee und clyde kündigt der seinen
job
nun müssen sie in florida so schnell wie
möglich ein zuhause finden
und das soll hier in cape coral stehen
das steht das ist schön dass ich sport
der sich kurz scheller als familie
kriegen zu wollen wir das
ok corral hat 160 tausend einwohner und
ist stolz auf den übernamen waterfront
wonderland mit über 600 km kanälen
stellt die stadt selbst venedig und
amsterdam in den schatten
[Musik]
so schön die straße schon unterschrieben
dennis und clyde dancer suchen ein haus
für vier personen und einen hund ihre
töchter frank und larissa warten in der
schweiz bis die eltern ein neues zuhause
gefunden haben
[Musik]
ja aber das bis dahin ist aber leider
hatte panische madrid
das haus kostet 115 1000 dollar
dennis und clyde bundes unbedingt kaufen
das passiert halt schon raum special
[Musik]
in kanada arbeiten christina und hermann
schönbächler an ihrem auto unterstand
[Musik]
christina schönbächler reist wurzeln aus
dem boden um eine ebene fläche für den
auto unterstand zu schaffen
blumen ab
mm
[Applaus]
so verknüpfen
british open
[Musik]
das muss nicht probiert es anders und
viel loser woche das liebespaar
[Musik]
warum bringst vorstellbar für junge
stadt mit alcala das ist das ist gut so
jetzt kann ich ein traktor
so papa
da
jetzt muss man hört den autokratischen
heizkörper oder muss ich machen wenn du
am liebsten mit dem thema wasser so
macht wenn du am liebsten natürlich und
manchmal braucht selbst ein tausendsassa
wie hermann hilfe
denn papier ist der raum ziehen
nur zu oft
nur der dow jones newswires
stoßen
vorjahr
draußen
nein gestimmt heißt du mit luther
stimmen sie zu geld machen
ich verstehe gut dass gegen jene
mehrheit könne welche gibt
[Musik]
foul von kevin tobler warten seit tagen
auf einen anruf der maklerin sie haben
sich für das haus beworben dass ihnen so
gut gefallen hat
es kostet 1600 franken im monat und wäre
sofort bezugsbereit
wichtig auch wenn man das klo gegriffen
das natel im ried schalten
[Musik]
ich habe
strand und meer da ist schon teil von
dem traum von affären ich denke
irgendwann ist dann kann man da auch
nicht immer machen aber wenn man schon
da 7 und mehr vor der haustüre haben
oder säuglinge trat das ein normaler
zeitung lebens genießen da ist wo es
eigentlich mal gedacht zu familien
weiße bluse
bei invista unglück des kurses haben
hängt demokratie aber denkt da hängt
aber die vorbei
weiter ist
[Musik]
in drei tagen kommen emma und die kinder
rolls plan ist geplatzt
er wollte seine immer ein gemütliches
nest einrichten
morgen ist sie sehr schmale riege
zweifel war damit dem user anderer
betrieb da bricht ein crash windel die
stadt rang im moment hat vier bahnen
schlafsitz nachricht und dem man
dementsprechend ich war schon er
übermüdet und ja er hat sehr viel
geschrieben ob da wirklich richtig ich
war mal darum macht man hier geht es ja
eigentlich der schweiz und digitales
habe ich eigentlich sehr schmal
hypophyse sie die familie wirklich
gezweifelt größeres im reich und nach
alle immer wenn das ganze umfeld mängel
seite tja sind ganz sicher wenn dann
wirklich untrainierter aufgeben sind wir
eigentlich mehr dazwischen sind sowohl
überzeugt
[Musik]
er war voller tatendrang und jetzt
bleibt ihm nichts anderes übrig als zu
warten
[Musik]
also das haus von ihnen ältere da bin
ich fast 20 jahren fertig jetzt da er
hat sogar mal ein paar uhr
bisher ist das haus fertig ist
marinierte nein ich werde nichts laufen
und wann immer das übrigens nicht
lieblingsbild von meiner frau
doch sieht man sich da gab es freut uns
und freude am traktor umgesetzt
nachwuchs ins haus
durch solche schlafzimmer es spartanisch
klima lektorin und ich auch sehr schmal
aus dem husum zu sehen die der schweiz
haben im hotel kommt und jetzt nach zehn
tagen training durchlaufen und sieht man
also habe ich mir natürlich einen wunsch
erfüllt habe ich eigene bis war
wenn man hallplatz hand wollen und wenn
ich auf dem thron nicht wie eigentlich
fremd weil
das leben wenn man geschwitzt begehren
halten
[Musik]
und jetzt
für den bau verwendet hans jörg jäger
speziell gut isolierende backsteine
gegen die tropische hitze macht und wie
sieht's eigentlich vorwärts geht und ich
weiß dass der grund steigende sehr
steilen oktober meiste zeit aber neben
drittel sind der hansetage macht wenn
ihr bezogen die bauarbeiten überwacht
ein schweizer der schon seit jahren hier
liebt damit im verein stimmen im schlaf
was ich glaube dass ich mich frage wo
steht nur genau dass das so über uns
nahe stehen kommt jetzt darauf an
ständen immer wieder nach einer genau
machen einfach das was wenn ein hund und
seither bringt nur um wende verschlafen
das geschafft sie möchte ich doch auf
der asse ich habe zwar mit dem video und
juckreiz hat das doch okay so musik oder
als muster sieht hopp gemacht
hier sind ja gut höre versetzt
so wird versichert haben sie dort
gemacht dass gott ich weiß aber dass
immer gesagt wenn du hausbauer oder so
der kopf ist nicht weg geht dann kann
sie gibt unglück oder details hat mit
troy bei jeder hat immer geist
gute geist eigentlich ja
[Musik]
clyde denzer ist auf der flucht auf der
flucht vor dem eintönigen alltagstrott
in der schweiz in florida will er ein
neues leben anfangen
es scheint als sei der autoverkäufer von
jenem leiden befallen
das in seiner wahlheimat usa erfunden
worden war
die midlife crisis
zwischen fünf und zehn jahren
wir haben hier krankt und und und das
ist so als ob das noch nicht genug
so
[Musik]
dennis tänzer unterstützte ihren mann
stets sie selber wäre aber nie auf die
idee gekommen auszuwandern
[Musik]
bezüglich seiner und ich auch
viel schönen rahmen für sich
ich gebe ihnen dass ich mag
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
seit tagen wollten deutlich zum kleid
tänzer auf die zusage für ihr traumhaus
und nicht nur rumzusitzen schauen sie
sich weiterer häuser an
das war ein foul
natürlich stehe ich jetzt nicht die
panik oder zogen monat also das ist
irgendwie sagen und während die
auswanderer sind mit den nerven am ende
seit einer geschlagenen woche warten sie
auf eine gute nachricht der maklerin
was müssen schickte mrosek sind immer
noch nicht mehr
larissa und franca sind ungeduldig die
töchter warten in der schweiz bis in
florida alles geregelt ist
[Musik]
und das hält
was hätte aus was hast du alles nein
das wohnhaus das ist okay so der
erleichterung
wir sind gerade mit den kindern nahmen
die messer in schach und müssen wir
jetzt noch nicht wissen noch nichts und
jetzt können wir den status gerade einen
super perfekt war vielen dank vielen
dank du bist du bist hier laufen die
glücksfee
[Musik]
und so wird es nächste woche weiter an
familie tänzer wohnt endlich in ihrem
neuen haus in florida
der amerikanische traum kann beginnen
in thailand trifft die erste rentnerin
ein
doch die seniorenresidenz ist alles
andere als bezugsbereit
in australien wohnt familie tobler auf
dem campingplatz statt im eigenen haus
den ersten geburtstag von baby jennifer
meyer die familien in z
christina und hermann schönbächler
bekommen besuch aus der schweiz
sie sind mittlerweile eine
sehenswürdigkeit in kanada
[Musik]
sie will